Hey, I have a question Brittany,
which is, you can read people,
How do you think I would do?
I've never skydived before
if I came to sign up and you knew me
or you know me as well as you know me,
how do you think I would do?
I think you will do okay.
I mean, you're very tall,
so that's a big consideration
because you have a lot of like,
a lot more body than I do
so you can control the wind more.
Oh, so that's a plus.
It's a plus if you do it right.
(chuckles)
Like, if you're on the front of me
and you're doing all sorts of crazy stuff,
you're gonna outfly me, you know?
So you have to really...
Well, I would be flailing a lot.
(laughing)
I mean, I'm just telling you right now,
I'd be flailing and you'd
be behind me, right?
Yes, and nobody could
see me cause I'm small
They wouldn't see you.
People would think I
was parachuting alone.
I'm so tall and gangly.
Right, which will be cool for you.
(laughs)
Right, but here's,
I can tell you a few things for a fact :
One, my arms and legs
would be flailing wildly.
(nodding)
Okay.
I would be shrieking,
and not like a yee haw shriek,
but a shriek of impending doom.
Right. Right.
Crying.
And I would be trying to
reach back and claw at you.
I'd been trying to physically
claw and attack you
because the fear part of my
brain, which is not reasonable,
would be blaming you
and wanting to kill you.
You know what I mean?
I get it, I get it.
That's just honest.
Yeah, no, I get it.
And you know what? The honesty is helpful.
Cause then I can prepare for
it and just like knock you out
before we get out or whatever.
(laughing)
Yeah, you should bring men.
You should bring us.
It'd be your first dive that you ever did
with a powerful syringe
of horse tranquilizer.
Yes, right.
And just as we get out of the door.
When I would land.
Now, when you land, how hard do you land?
I've heard. It's like, you can
hurt yourself when you land.
It's like, you're going,
it's like jumping off what?
A 10 foot wall or an eight
foot wall or something.
So not anymore. Back when we
jumped with the round shoots,
that was, but now they
fly a lot more forwards.
There's a lot of forward
speed and we just slide it
on our butts and it's actually quite soft.
Okay. Okay.
I think in world war II,
a lot of people, they jump out of planes
and they break their leg when they landed,
because if you didn't do it
just right, it was nasty.
You are coming straight down.
And what's your biggest fear of something
that you might land in
accidentally when you land?
Let's just say you get blown off course,
what's the thing you would
least want to land in?
So I have never had this experience,
but other people have,
if you land in, you know,
you can look for a field
if you're not going to land
at the airport and sometimes there's bulls
or like other aggressive animals.
And apparently that's not
a great place to land.
Can you imagine being a ball
and you're in a bad mood anyway,
and then this jackass
just falls out of the sky
and lands and knocks
over your water trough.
So can you land and then you're
attacked immediately, right?
Right, exactly.
Like you survive the skydive
and then you get killed by a bull.
(gasps)
I would try. I would love to,
if I got blown off course,
I would want to land at
a big festive occasion,
like a wedding that was pretty fancy.
Right, cause everybody
gets so excited to see you.
Well also I'd want
to smash into a bunch of
stuff like cake, you know.
I would love to land on someone's wedding
during a pretty important
part, smashed into the cake,
knock over all the wine,
slam into the, you know,
the bride and the groom.
Just, you know what I mean?
And then, and then,
and then get up and act like
you guys ruined my skydiving.
Right. It is their fault.
Yeah, that's what I would do.
If you come do a tandem with me,
we can find a wedding and we'll do that.
Okay. You know, I have
never gone skydiving before
and I have to admit,
it terrifies me.
But if I did it,
I would want to do it
with you, I really would.
Oh, thank you.
No, you seem very cool
and I would trust you a 100%
and you also seem very funny.
I think we have a good time.
Well, thank you, I think we would too.
Yeah. I want to reserve a
slot with you if I do it.
Okay. All right.
I'm not saying a 100% I'm going to do it.
No, that's okay.
Pretty sure I'm going to make,
I'm going to do something embarrassing.
It's going to be in there.
The flailing and you know.
The flailing and the shrieking.
And you're probably going
to make, I know you,
you're going to have
one of those GoPros on,
and you are going to get
all the footage of me
begging for my life,
cursing you out, shrieking.
The crying.
Yeah. Yelling at God
saying, "I blame God."
Yeah. Just completely breaking
down as a human being,
becoming a child, babbling,
crying, soiling myself.
And then you would probably,
you would put that online.
I know you would.
Well yeah, it would go viral, so.
(laughing)